Київ та НАТО започаткували співпрацю
одразу ж після здобуття Україною незалежності.
Проте стратегія українських президентів у цьому питанні
була різною.
Активно рухатися у бік Альянсу Київ почав за президентства Леоніда Кучми.
За його активної участі було затверджено План дій Україна-НАТО.
А також - записано як ціль вступ до Альянсу у Військової доктрині країни,
схваленій у 2004-му.
Проте у тому ж році процес загальмувався.
На саміті у Стамбулі країни-члени НАТО дали зрозуміти -
без демократичних виборів про членство Україна може і не мріяти.
Як наслідок, Кучма вирішив відмовитись від натівського курсу.
Але це тривало недовго.
Черговий розворот зовнішньої політики відбувся із Віктором Ющенком
на чолі держави.
Саме з ним Київ був найближче до вступу до Альянсу.
У 2008 році генсеку НАТО було направлено
так званий "лист трьох"
- президента Ющенка, прем’єрки Тимошенко та спікера Яценюка,
у якому ті просили про долучення України
до так званого ПДЧ -
Плану дій з членства в Альянсі.
Це мало би стати початком формальної процедури вступу до НАТО.
Проте на саміті у Бухаресті у 2008 році
Київ отримав відмову.
Згодом сайт Wikileaks опублікував таємні документи,
з яких випливало, що проти ПДЧ для України
виступили Франція та Німеччина -
начебто через побоювання негативної реакції з боку Росії.
Після обрання президентом Віктора Януковича у 2010 році
знову розпочався процесс віддалення від Альянсу
та зближення з Росією.
Україна оголосила про позаблоковий статус,
а ухвалені парламентом сумнозвісні "харківські угоди"
дозволили російському флоту залишатися в Криму
до 2042 року.
Після Революції гідності Україна вкотре взяла курс на зближення з Альянсом.
У червні 2017-го
Верховна Рада затвердила членство в НАТО як пріоритет зовнішньої політики.
Утім, на відміну від Тбілісі,
Київ поки не подавав заявку на членство.
А президент Порошенко на початку року
оголосив про намір провести референдум з цього питання.
Ставлення українців до вступу до Альянсу
за роки незалежності було неоднозначним.
Однак різко змінилося після анексії Криму та окупації частини Донбасу.
Якщо до 2013 року
вступ України до НАТО підтримували лише до 20% українців,
то нині кількість прихильників цієї ідеї - близько 50%.
Про подальшу політичну підтримку України та співпрацю із Києвом
заявляють і в самому Альянсі.
Проте в Брюсселі визнають: до членства України в НАТО іще далеко.